this video was brought to you by origin
pc hello
welcome come on in oh
glad you could make it on my 2017
office tour ah
take it all in
look at that bam
custom chair son custom
stuff other things oh wow it's free
real estate all right where do i begin
let's start off
hey i'm over here let's
let's start off with what everyone wants
to see
which is of course marzia the computer
chair is very important too but computer
brand new baby
i got this today i just barely set it up
uh i'm very excited to finally be
showing it off
as you know i've been working with
origin pc wonderful people
wonderful that's what they are they are
people
and i got it today i just set it up it
looks
so sick i didn't think i could get like
a more
beasty computer than my last one but
here we are this is not a beast
this is a monster rare i'm a monster too
the specs but pewter what are the specs
okay they like they even signed it so
cute
we got the origin pc genesis this is
their case
i love it it looks amazing custom
painted
uh unfortunately you don't see it but on
this side it says squad fam
if you look here inside we got the ad
that that what is that
what is that the brofist logo custom and
even on the graphics card it looks
this is the mona lisa of computers guys
okay
i know you're jealous very nice case
it's so easy to
access everything in the back i
constantly have to change stuff
even got the front nice and covered of
course you know the most important thing
is that you can
show up different colors to your your
wineman aren't you impressed
like it changes color margin each of
these computers are custom made
and i am so proud to be the first one to
unveil
this brand new model of a computer and
be the first one
to own it to actually have it so cool
we're gonna give away a computer as well
that's been kissed by me that's right
so check out the link in description for
that anything that you want to access
i don't know for some reason i don't
know what this does but
i don't know what i do here but uh if i
needed to do it
i can do it okay it's got an asus prime
x2 299.
i'm guessing that's the motherboard it's
liquid cool intercourse i
9 baby 2.6 gigahertz
god damn that's powerful i need that
when i'm playing roblox
64 gigabyte ddr4 memory
look at them they're lit up too i can
change the color on those biggers
why are you laughing it's cool okay
what's so funny about this do a liquid
cooled
nvidia gtx 1080 with my little
signature on there sli that's for when
i'm
recording happy wheels you need that
extra extra power
okay you need that super strength this
is like
two really strong swedish men right here
doesn't get more powerful than this is
what i'm trying to say 500 gigabyte
samsung 960 evo and then we have four
terabyte samsung 850 evo ssd
the memory is somewhere inside the
computer
it's really good it's super fast memory
which is good for me
obviously because you have no memory
okay great good one 1.3
kilowatt evga supernova g2 psu
which clear things that's the liquid
cooling
that's cool that it is cool don't drink
it though
you'll feel bad now of course you know
i'm not just some pleb
that gets this amazing computer of
course i treat her with respect
look at the cable management here guys
my god
so if you come back come here come here
mr
a very nice a very nice so
all of that goes in here and then all
the crap gets we don't need to lift this
one
but uh it's it's very it's very nicely
organized in there
okay very nice then we have all the
cables going up
watch your head marcia oh no what's
happening oh
oh so obviously i need to be able to
move this desk up and forth
but the cable they still need to be
the right length perfect solution
incredible felix you're a genius i know
look at that cable management whenever i
see someone with the knives pc i'm like
well show me your cables
you call that cable management you
disgust me
let's take it down a notch first of all
origin pc god bless you uh i work with a
lot of sponsors but they've been just a
joy to work with
i cannot recommend their product enough
i i'm so happy with this computer
if you want to check it out yourself
link in the description
obviously uh appreciate you supporting
them and supporting me at the same time
namaste moving on with the rest of the
setup i have three
asus what do they call them they're ben
they're curved
they're curved three so ah okay
ah so very nice
you know how nice it is to have curved
screens three of them
this is how you get women martin thank
you for letting me know
no no no this is how i got you
sure the mouse mat look at this mouse
man how big is it it's so big look how
big it
big this is very nice
got the coarse hair mechanic keyboard
but it's silent you know when i record
videos you don't want to hear my
keyboard half the time what if i'm
clicking very nice textured
very nice right you can say very nice
did you just me
ah gotta thank you uh
why don't you keep look you know your
stuff huh it's a mouse it's
click on it it's got a nice click on it
right really you feel the power in the
click
because you know i have so much power
and i needed to try and slay
when i'm slaying noobs you know what i'm
saying
you know you know exactly what i'm
saying microphone what i'm using
is uh i got this recently
it's not golden but you can't really see
it
akg honestly they're all the same don't
spend money on a nice microphone it's an
xlr so it goes into this roland
uh audio interface i've been through
like five of these
none of them work this one barely works
i don't understand microphones can
someone help me
it's always some issue with audio and it
doesn't even sound that great
but i double up with pop filters because
you know i'm going
to pop you don't want your ears to
explode
you're welcome i think when i record
basically just pull this down bam
bam got my canon
usually i record with the camera mars is
using right now but this i put it up
there just so you get an idea
it goes straight in my into my computer
and uh since this is a new computer i
don't have the uh
i don't have the like software or
whatever i usually record with obs
just turn the [ __ ] on bam we're good to
go
recording straight to my computer
very nice and easy it's all made to
matey's oh i want to stand out oh no no
big deal chair get out of the way as
much as i love you get out of the way
hey guys this is peter pack huh how easy
was that
done send that [ __ ] to brad done
of course got my legendary headphones
you can't find these anywhere because we
sell them on the website but
you can't i mean you can't find them you
can you should
find them got the beautiful pewds
signature on them look at that
look at that girlfriend's logo as well
my god
oh they fit like perfectly hey pewds
you have pretty cool headphones you got
a pretty cool setup
you got a brand new computer but can you
do this
ah so comfortable
obviously i love this chair it's
gorgeous
it's sexy but it's still subtle
clutch i love you thank you for
making this with me oh what's this over
here
oh godzilla what are you doing excuse me
good fella
let's keep that burglars away you know
my uh
50 million plaque no big deal almost at
60 now
who's counting got uh this one
speaker very nice was given to me by
spotify thank you
i love it very nice swedish design
and of course my cars figurines a lot of
people asked about these
i actually have a tattoo from one of his
figurines
which is like the most unintentional
hypebeast thing to do i didn't know
like it was part of some kind of culture
to have figurines but
i love them you gifted them to me didn't
you she did
i love them thank you got it lit up with
the custom
whatever i don't know it's just it's
nice you know
light can really change a room this is a
very small room but i really like it
that way because
it feels cozy like before i used to be
in an office and i had so much space and
it just felt weird like
when you're in front of your computer
you want it to be your little man cave
right
was that it i don't know why am i your
green screen oh of course
of course so genius as i am
i bought a projector right sound isn't
the most pleasing sound but
i painted it green probably could have
picked a better
more greenish tone but it works it works
pretty well
boom green screen right away no problem
easy are you not impressed like that's
genius
i know have you seen anyone else on
youtube do that no
because i'm 10 steps ahead of everyone
now i could probably just pay some
guy to do all this for me but and make
it 10 times better but
it's more personal this way you know
it's he's quiet when he goes up i don't
understand why it's so loud when i take
it down
of course you think you know everything
don't you what's that behind the
computer feelings oh
don't worry i got all my [ __ ] in these
boxes
i also put up the the vibe sensors
so that i can since you guys like the vr
videos
so everything is meant to be as easy as
possible
i think when you're recording videos
every single day you really need
things to just
it saves you so much time yeah i don't
want to just like oh i have to shoot
this video oh
i gotta set this up like it's it's all
bam bam bam bing scream
and it's nice everything matches
perfectly you get the perfect black
red white hue it's all
very well thought out even small details
you know
oh what's this uh this is just my
amazing
honor 7x with my custom pop socket also
matching of course it's matching
why are you even asking you really feel
like a king in here wait i'm not done
yet i'm not done yet
okay well i'll see you later leave a
like
for real i need you back here though the
genesis pc
it's the most advanced custom built
computer in the world
it doesn't get better than this this is
the top of the top
and it's my pleasure and privilege
to be owning one of these bad boys if
you get one of these
you get them for life you get 24 hour
custom servers
for life okay they're not just selling
you something and it's shoving you out
in the desert they say hey
we got water too i know what you're
thinking oh pierce you're just showing
all this
stuff out what about me don't worry i
got you
check out originpc.com pewdiepie we're
gonna give away
a computer that i've been using it makes
it better if i've been using it okay
all the files will be there all the
history
all the data think about it
you're super zoomed in right now yeah
you are
i can see the lights